bonjour à tous alors aujourd'hui on va
aborder un thème un peu
à quoi sert les
alors mon but
révolutionner ni de remettre en question
les cols d'accord aujourd'hui je
montrais de pas mon parcours
ce que j'ai pu comprendre un petit peu
de du monde du travail et surtout de
compétence qu'on ne s'acquiert pas à
l'école on va surtout parler de savoir
être donc ces trois chiffres 90 75 70
c'est une évolution physique un sens
rien à voir c'est tout simplement le
dernier chic qui sont en sortie de l'
enquête sur les anciens élèves de
l'université savoie mont blanc dont 90%
c'était le pourcentage de satisfaction
globale des anciens élèves sur
l'enseignement sur les apports
théoriques pratiques et ses 75 ans dont
pourcentage encore une fois c'est le
nombre de personnes qui ont été
satisfaits de par le contenu de la
formation un peu plus détaillé et 70%
c'est l'adéquation entre les formations
qu'ils ont réalisés et leur poste dans
l'entreprise
alors la question c'est pourquoi le
pourcentage diminue
et bien parce qu'une compétence ou des
compétences qu'on ne voit pas les cols
dont je dédie au tout début
c'est le savoir être il ya plusieurs
compétences que je vous énumérez de par
mon parcours qui sont importantes de
prendre en compte
donc on va voir ça ensemble en cp j'ai
eu un terme peut en plus inconnu comme
ça ces classes préparatoires aux grandes
écoles
donc c'est tout ce qui est mathieu maths
spé pour ceux qui connaissent ce pc est
6ème psi donc maths physique chimie etc
et donc ça c'était mon premier cursus
j'ai fait un an là dedans tout ce qui
est mat physique-chimie j'en ai bouffé
des équations des équations
différentielles
après on va faire une étude sur pendule
non je plaisante bon ça ira beaucoup
d'apport aux théorique l'action
énormément j'ai mangé en veut plus trop
maintenant mais j'ai pris beaucoup de
choses et comme je vous le dis donc j'ai
fait qu'un an
parce que j'avais pas les bons résultats
parce que je travaillais pas
correctement
donc j'ai du coup j'ai du coup je suis
parti sur une autre filière on verra
après et dans ma tête je repartis sur
une filière inférieurs parce que classes
préparatoires ça fait quand même et puis
du coup je partis sur un des buts est
donc la remise en question remise en
question pourquoi parce que on se dit
ouah mais finalement on dit vitesse sert
à quoi et bien vous allez le voir après
on en apprend beaucoup sur soi quand
même on se remet en question il m'a en
fait il ya peut-être d'autres cursus qui
sont plus intéressants pour telle ou
telle personne d'accord dut sg m ah bon
c'est pas jacob ca technolac donc ces
jeunes dut donc sciences et génie des
matériaux là dessus j'ai appris un truc
basique c'est que l'école c'est un
mélange de théorie et de pratique et
qu'on peut pas tout comprendre si on
regarde des bouquins ou si on a des
cours en amphi ok il faut savoir aussi
mettre en pratique tout ça donc j'ai pu
le découvrir deux par les travaux
pratiques tout simplement par un parent
un stage et par rapport aux stages je me
suis rendu compte qu'en fait on n'était
pas s'est bien préparé pour le monde de
l'entreprise
du coup je me suis dit moi je vais
partir sur une alternance et c'est là
que je partis sur une licence pro idei
toujours à technolac un leurre on me dit
pourquoi ils adorent c'est comme
universelles universités
savoie-mont-blanc licence pro innovation
et développement industriel basiquement
c'est de la gestion de projet la
planification de projets et la
communication par rapport à ça des
compétences assez transverse et il a ça
m'a plu là j'ai eu le déclic en plus et
en alternance donc je me suis je me suis
confronté au monde de l'entreprise
et là j'ai compris que qu'on devait non
seulement faire attention à comment
communiquer avec les personnes jusqu en
tant que jeune on est souvent là que
l'étiquette de prétention
d'accord au départ parce qu'on passe
qu'on arbore un sourire parce qu'on est
content parce qu'on a envie d'apprendre
on propose des choses donc on est
souvent considérée comme prétentieux et
c'est là où il faut s'adapter et en fait
pour prendre en compte leurs remarques 1
comme je l'aï dit tout à l'heure une
remise en question est en fait s'adapter
hockey et j'ai appris aussi beaucoup par
l'erreur quand je quand je rentrais du
boulot
donc j'avais c'était deux semaines de
cours et deux semaines d'entreprise
quand je rentrais du num du boulot jg
mais en fait je passe mon temps à
apprendre parce que je fais beaucoup
d'erreurs ça fait un peu bateau comme ça
mais vous verrez que vous comprendrez
comme ça en fait en en faisant des
erreurs
le but d'en faire le moins possible suis
d'accord mais il ya des erreurs vous
allez forcément faire qu'on va le
renvoyer dans le monde de l'entreprise
voulait proposer des choses faut faire
attention à tout cela
d'accord on va passer ensuite au master
management de projet donc là encore une
fois une en alternance sur deux ans et
là j'ai appris un truc encore une fois
très important c'est s'adapter
je le répète souvent mais c'est des
choses qu'on n'a pas forcément
conscience quand on est étudiant on a
des cours sur du management sur du
leadership de la compta voilà ce à quoi
tout ça on comprend en fait
l'interaction en fait dans l'entreprise
comment les gens s'organisent comme les
gens travaillent le management à quoi à
quoi sert un entreprise
ça sert à gérer des personnes n'y a pas
que ça c'est aussi pour les motiver pour
les encourager vers un but comme la
perle à la fin la performance des tirs
un appel tout à l'heure et en fait le
but c'est de voir l'interaction de tout
ça quand vous avez tous vos cours
essayez de voir plus grand paddy rend
fou si j'ai pas compris grand chose avec
cette personne je n'ai pas encore vu
l'intérêt du court essayez de voir plus
loin et comprendre en fait l'intérêt
pour vous plus tard
d'accord vous verrez que ça vous aider
plus tard et en fait on dit non c'est à
l'école
ouais y avait des trucs c'est quand même
pas mal et en alternance si vous avez
l'occasion de faire de l'alternance ou
même du stage je suis moi aussi on sait
très bien vous verrez que l'homme
de l'entreprise certes il n'est pas
évident mais vous pourrez quand même
passé de très bons moments et si vous
prenez le temps de comprendre les gens
nous adapter et donc de le faire
attention à tout cela ma conclusion par
rapport à tout cela c'est que l'école
nous apprendre beaucoup de choses
beaucoup d'apports théoriques
par contre et des compétences qui sont
transverses qui sont communes à chaque
achat qu hier qu'on fasse près pas qu'on
fasse un bac pro qu'on va scinder buts
et peu importe la filière la façon de se
remettre en question d'être d'être
humble de se poser les bonnes questions
d'apprendre par l'erreur et surtout de
s'adapter s'adapter aux personnes qu'on
va rencontrer aux personnes avec qui on
va communiquer je vais finir par un
dernier exemple il faut quand même que
chez des exemples pour que soient plus
concret en master je devais présenter
enfin avec mon responsable devrait
présenter une une politique qualité
bon je vous épargne les détails mais en
gros on doit voir le l'accord de la
direction
et pour avoir l'accord de la direction
va alors parler bien entendu il faut
motiver le la direction il faut montrer
l'intérêt pour la personne
bonjour ai parlé à mon résultat mais je
me mets la folle à en parler faut y
aller on va commencer les choses vous
voyez les mêmes responsables me dit non
mais pas tout de suite
on va commencer et puis après on verra
pour ça je dis mais là ça c'est le
première étape c'est sa deuxième pièce
ça faut y aller quoi t'es pas d'accord
tu viennes les bases et j'y suis allé
j'ai envoyé un petit mail et pièces
jointes j'ai regardé trois fois mais
comme on nous le dit de faire attention
et là j'arrive devant la direction et je
dis pas vous avez vu mon mail oui je les
ai vus et vous en pensez quoi c'est une
ébauche on peut travailler tu n'y a pas
de souci me regarde et me dit mais pas
vous de faire ça c'est pas à lancer pas
vous de faire ça vous devez faire ça
vous étonne alternant vous n'êtes pas
faire ça un accord donc quelle est la
leçon
bon c'était pas que la personne aînée
n'y comprenez rien c'était pas ça au
contraire c'est qu'il ya un moment pour
tous voilà faut faire attention on peut
proposer des choses
faut juste prendre le temps la façon le
faire ce n'est pas le bon moment c'est
on l'a maintenant la personne est plus
réceptif donc on peut on peut le lancer
mais pas tout de suite
faut juste attendre et de patients et
s'adapter encore une fois aux personnes
c'est très important ça vous aidera pour
plus tard merci à pons
[Applaudissements]